good enough
that's a lot of friends
I know all my friends leave me oh you're
all your friends
somebody for 15 minutes ago oh why don't
they like me
why Jason show me his penis because of
Madison Square Garden
oh yeah but this is what in fact you
know what actually since you interrupted
I want you to introduce this if you
introduce it dude okay excuse me
I would get my voice ready
in
in every episode of Genius wearing
podcast we have our amazing host Jimmy
Marshall owner David so so our very
special guest one of the best uh
personal trainers in the world
Kinesiology
Kinesiology
uh program certificate bachelor degree I
did not know this and I learned it from
David and we have a trainer Nick
so you pronounce your last name right
yeah what else how else yeah that's it
Nick died and David Soul everybody walk
over and that was really good take over
and who are you what in the [ __ ] were we
on The Price is Right
if you host a show is that how you do it
but I do if you hosted a show literally
the first 10 minutes of show it's just
you doing that the whole time
Cadence
that's you the whole time it's it's
literally two marbles fighting each
other in your brain they just Clank you
around
dude every time you talk you give me
[ __ ] anxiety holy [ __ ] I'm always
just like just say it
do you know what the next word is my
name is
Jason
I'll [ __ ] kill you
so much anxiety you piece of [ __ ]
oh God so we have Jason Jenny here once
again we have Nick The Ear The Genius
brain podcast is rolling once again been
doing this podcast now for [ __ ] I
think five years now oh yeah man whoa
It's been a long time how do you feel
about that does that make you excited
like hey bro I could do this for [ __ ]
another five years you know it's weird
so when I was back at home so every
every year towards like November
December I do the same thing I I always
do like a month-long uh like reflection
of what I want to do next year I didn't
do that a lot during pandemic because
literally nothing was happening I was
swinging on a [ __ ] swing just jacking
off to anybody that walked by my window
[Laughter]
[Music]
but every year I'll kind of do this
thing where I go okay what did I do this
year that I didn't like that I want to
change and what's the thing I want to do
next year that I have to [ __ ] do and
we were touching on it now so it's
interesting because I always give you
[ __ ] about this and give you Shin too
but I don't shouldn't because it's out
of love though yeah it's like this idea
you know what I talk about love bro no
we don't talk about love we only talk
about hate dude I hate Asians I hate
everybody dude how many Asian did you
beat up 13. and they all look just like
because I hate myself boom googie punch
pal anyways this is going to cancel me
real soon I'm cutting this all out
because I'm editing it
he's gonna leave it in here yeah but I
do this thing where I reflect and the
one thing that I kind of realized that I
do that you [ __ ] do a lot too is like
we always like prevent ourselves from
um achieving things that we want because
we feel that we don't deserve it yeah
right like we give ourselves excuses to
not do it yeah like I I realize it's
about myself I tend not to self-promote
at all yeah like my Instagram so and I
was literally going to Tweet this and I
didn't tweet it because I thought about
it that it was like I was talking to
myself so like you if you're like in
entertainment right and I think one of
the smartest things that you can do and
I've been watching this cat named La
Russell the Russell is a rapper out in
the Bay Area from Oakland I [ __ ] love
this kid dude this kid is like 10 years
younger than me but he inspires me and
the reason why is because this kid has
like an undying amount of just like
respect for himself and he promotes
himself as if he is the brand like you
should run your Instagram account your
things that you put out as if it's a
brand as if your your job was to promote
this company
why can't we do it for ourselves yeah
it's it feels gross a little bit and
that's it that's how I feel too I hate
it though but I watched this kid Russell
right
and I see how much like belief he has in
himself and not only do you have to have
a belief in yourself you have to have a
product to show yeah so he puts his
money where his [ __ ] mouth is yeah
one of the most healthiest relationships
with his fan base that I've ever seen in
my life wow he has a mic he raps He
makes music and he gives like really
great advice and it's a lot about
self-affirmation and like I can't do it
like whenever I try to promote something
like even like this matcha brand right
have I promoted it once on my page and
we've been open for a month and I can't
do it because I feel like I feel like
I'm like a car salesman yeah you feel
sleazy I feel sleepy too right I feel
like it's like hey guys have you heard
about matcha well guess what matcha has
antioxidants
you know yeah yeah and I just feel like
this you turn into me you know what it
is though I'll tell you what it is what
when you like say I were to post
something like promote buy business I
know I'll look at it right after and be
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you
piece of [ __ ] you are what is that
annoying like nobody like you know like
you just say everything like it's like
negative self-talking obviously but it's
like where does that come from yeah you
know what I mean but then that's why you
know as long as you gotta talk to other
people about this because it's not
something that you only go through and I
feel like it's a lot more common than
people think but some people will just
never acknowledge that because I'll
watch like other people right who are
[ __ ] delusional like they suck oh
that's not what I meant so bad like when
I look at them I'm like you're terrible
at what you do not only are you either
like either not funny or not musically
talented you can't dance or whatever but
they believe in themselves so much and
I'm like how do I tap into this yeah
like how do you do it like you're but
you don't want that you don't want that
you don't want that I want a little bit
of yeah I mean like you think like
literally they could be the most hideous
person on earth right but in their mind
their GQ Magazine's sexy yeah that might
be the way though how do they do it like
how do you have that little
self-awareness but also there's a lot of
them are successful that way though
exactly we're so successful okay well
this is the question do you feel do you
ever fear that you'll be like those
people is yes is that what's holding you
back do you feel because I feel like
that too right right that's why like I
think the other thing too like when you
ambushed me with the stand-up thing
you know what I mean like I had to be
faced with this fear of hey are you just
funny to this crowd or are you just are
you a funny person in general and having
to face that fear is very [ __ ] hard
because in my mind I'm like oh like yeah
I say a few funny things here and there
and I need to stand up when I was
younger but that doesn't mean I could do
it now yeah you know yeah so it's
interrupt you but the thing is like
that's what I'm saying but that crowd
doesn't matter is the thing see that I
think that's the key right it doesn't it
really doesn't it
but you're gonna apply that to anything
right like this guy
he's a crazy
say you're promoting your business right
you're promoting your business and then
you're worried that like oh like I'm
gonna [ __ ] I'm annoy people or
whatever the [ __ ] like that also doesn't
matter either like you annoying somebody
yeah because you're promoting your
business that shouldn't matter to you
because you're at the end of the day
like we got to do what we got to do but
also there's like a thing like
um with promoting your business I feel
like you should not should maybe I would
do it more because it's not me I feel
like because we are because you're a
trainer Entertainer but it's like
Entertainer it's like if I have to be an
Entertainer and be like hey I'm an
Entertainer
but it's me though but then if I have
matcha I go
this is this is my product yeah yeah so
to me it's a little easier because it's
like I feel the same way too yeah
because it's not us because if it's us
like because we know we're pieces of
[ __ ]
we know where hot garbage hot garbage on
sale and we've been told that our whole
life bro but but no that's that's what
it is though too right like sometimes
you think that like oh I and I do this
with my own [ __ ] like oh dude I wish I
could just do someone else's that's what
I'm saying you know I said as I wish I
fantasize about working for someone
else's [ __ ] but then if I think I think
I would also do the same [ __ ] though if
I was David's manager he'd be way more
successful but I understand why like oh
yeah I can help somebody do that like oh
yeah I'll put you on the game like if I
was like for for instance like I don't
want to be all [ __ ] lame and [ __ ] but
like for you when you come over here and
you're like oh I don't know if like
sometimes you you second guess you're
funny all the time I think you're
[ __ ] great there's not a I don't want
this to be a whole [ __ ] suck because
that's not what I want you will like it
but continue but at the same time it's
like am I I'm like dude what are you
talking about
you're easy to Market like it's like
because we're on the outside and
sometimes it's easier it's like the idea
of running your brand like you were
running somebody else's yeah yeah but it
is hard and that's really so difficult
to do especially if you're a person
that's like self-aware yeah right but
now there's like a certain level of
detriment where it's like you're almost
like too self-aware to the point where
you just don't do anything at all and
like for the longest time that I've had
this channel the longest time I've had
my Instagram I rarely post on Instagram
yeah I rarely post on my YouTube aside
from the podcast because I enjoy the
podcast you have to do the [ __ ]
Twitter thing once a week bro that has
to be at the order I once every two
weeks it's so good like the [ __ ]
Fried Chicken one is good too yeah
you've been posting a lot of your tweets
dude you got to do it Twitter don't show
me no love dude and I'll [ __ ] them but
on the Instagram Twitter but yeah yeah
but these are like the type of things
too where I think about is like
when I see sometimes when people create
content they don't really they're just
creating content you know what I mean
like there's no like second guessing
they're successful
some of them yeah some of them right
some of them are successful right but
then at the same time like I think I'm
trying to get to that point where I'm
just basically just posting just because
right even if it doesn't do well who the
[ __ ] cares let it let it stay up there
right but then for me because I want
everything to hit honestly too it's like
the stand-up thing right I want
everything to hit you know and look not
everything will but as long as I put my
effort into it I'm okay with it right
but if I just do something random and it
hits it actually doesn't feel good to me
like there are times where like I'll do
something stupid and then next thing you
know it has like Sandy shared like 10
000 times and like why like why why was
that [ __ ] funny yeah
I hate you yeah I [ __ ] hate you but
that's what happens because people think
it's funny that's why so you know what
you taught me how to Grapple one time
you gotta stop doing that you did that
like five times the earlier podcast
baby
you gotta stop doing that it's gross hey
let me tell you something at least I
could do something with it
oh [ __ ] man that's [ __ ] up
your face yeah
even though this is new to me I didn't
know you felt that way about no that's
why for next year too my goal is to just
run my brand as if I'm running somebody
else's brand and I and you should too I
need to yeah that's right and it's like
this this idea of like self-belief and
then just being okay with just just
doing [ __ ] and putting like your whole
heart into it right like and I do that
with stuff where it's not my face like
secret society right I put that level of
effort into that clothing brand but my
face isn't on it so yeah I don't have to
worry about that yeah right I think we
just hate our faces our respective faces
dude I wish I was white
we've been filming all these like
exercise tutorials and stuff and then
like I it's honestly really hard for me
to edit them because I'm like shut the
[ __ ] up you stupid [ __ ] idiot you
sound so dumb and it's like sometimes I
gotta like remove myself for a little
bit and then be like I gotta come do
this at a clear headspace dude or I
gotta hire someone to do it for you he
knows this one this one dude we used to
train with and I'm talking about that
level of delusion I need to have this
guy would do like uh he goes this is how
you do this combo from Henry like Henry
host or [ __ ] whatever whatnot and we
sparred with him he's the worst one out
of all of us oh no but he's doing fight
tutorials and I'm like he's delusional I
need a little bit of that like I need
some of that because he like when he
does it I'm like oh he like he talks as
if he can do this he's in a real fight
situation yeah when literally you could
punch his face at any given time and
he'll never move his head yeah right and
so I look at somebody like that and I'm
like he believes it he believes it yeah
he really believes envy that yeah for
sure sure part of me used to feel I
think when I was younger part of me used
to have like a
that's what I'm looking for like
resentment towards people like that but
but then as I got older I realized like
oh no like they're just [ __ ] they're
just they're just they're being
themselves they're being obsessed
they're like oh I [ __ ] like I just
saw like a lot of what like you said for
your next year goals is like okay how do
I get closer to that yeah so I like
it's hard it's it's it's really because
it's the reflex is always like dude
you're [ __ ]
yeah never gonna do [ __ ] you pieces do
you think you guys think it's the peers
because sometimes I care about the peers
like um if I put something out and then
even though maybe normal people would
like it like maybe you're a client yeah
or people who follow but then my peers
is like I'm like Oh my butt is not good
enough it's the people you were sure for
sure the people you respect exactly the
people you respect but but I feel like a
lot of the times the people you respect
like I don't say they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't though but that's what it is
they want you to win anyways if you
don't love you anyways they understand
the game they're like yeah just go like
you know we I do like stand up or
something right and then like a bunch of
people are like that wasn't that funny I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah but then like I
said Dave Chappelle was like
that sucked I'd be like okay I'm gonna
kill myself excuse me yeah you know what
I mean like yeah that it just hits a
little different yeah you know what I
mean so it's like yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] about strangers but if it's like up
here right let's say like you saw me do
stand-up and then I just saw you in the
crowd just with your arms crossed going
like that I would literally go home and
I would land on a pile of knives
collect all the knives in my house and
jump on them
a bottle of knives I swear to God do it
dude you'll just see me drink a glass of
water to spray it everywhere
dude
that's what'll [ __ ] happen I swear to
God I just don't like that like that's
the thing too because I I tend to look
at other people's stuff too and they're
not my peers or anything but I'm like oh
God that's trash but then there's that
fear that I I'm I'm also trashed but
then that's the thing right it's like
everyone's like there's always going to
be a certain percentage of people that's
like gonna [ __ ] dunk on you you're
right there's always in your percentage
so it's like but I don't expect it it's
like yeah whatever but I also think that
we're critical because we're so critical
of ourselves yeah
that we are also critical about other
people or other things that we're like
oh man if we're gonna go ourselves and
other people then we have to live up to
that level two which is like stupid I
think it's like being authentic I think
like authenticity is very hard to find
right like yeah I think like when I saw
um like I I'm reminded of this too where
there was these uh two like YouTubers
right they wanted to do stand up and I
saw them do stand up and my god dude I
wanted to pluck my eyeballs out like it
was so bad yeah like it and the reason
why and I remember too just like having
a conversation with somebody because
we all did the same stand-up set right
and at this point I understand in a
couple years but I was like I'd still do
this [ __ ] I went up and I just used some
old bits reworked it and it was fine
yeah I got a few laughs it was okay I
saw them go up and you could tell they
worked their set really hard and it was
just hard like watching them I might
want maybe want to pull off every single
[ __ ] nail because if I was cringing
so hard but were they getting laughs no
and the reason why and I think they
didn't understand was like
they were trying to make jokes based on
what other people thought was funny and
it was inauthentic to their experience
like so for example they just moved to
LA and they wanted to talk about Mexican
culture it's like you don't have Mexican
friends you don't kick it with Mexican
folk yeah none of this is applicable
yeah right and so they did a random like
Mexican East L.A accent I'm dead silent
and I wanted to die for them have you
ever seen somebody bomb we're just like
I want to die now because I feel the
awkwardness taking knives out of this
bag
[Laughter]
drink this
the final check
this like I still remember this set he
goes you know what's so weird about La
it's like you like in Cape Town there's
so many Korean people but the streets
are called like West Colima oh
it's like you can't make jokes about
stuff you haven't experienced because
now you're also just kind of making a
character caricature right like when
people do that type of stuff it's funny
because it's like oh you know that
fool's about that [ __ ] life right
like I used to do the set about like how
Mexican people used to always make fun
of me because but that's just how they
make fun of their family members like
they have [ __ ] up nicknames for every
person I knew this kid I thought his
name was Gordo which just means fat yeah
yeah and then the whole time
hey you know my name's Josue right I was
like what yeah
what do you mean yeah he goes they call
me [ __ ] Gordo because you know I'm
fat and I'm like
no no dude your name's Gordo but they
would just call him
like inside just a lot of Mexican people
know about this and you can make these
like cultural jokes
but this vote just randomly was just
like [ __ ] let's go Lima and then you
just hear him extend that way and the
dead silence actually it really hurts
but but I feel like sometimes like when
people start like
um sometimes people just they they want
to do things to see to whatever that
make them laugh and like a fake thing
but it's um
you think he said that around his group
of friends and I got a big laugh and
he's like perfect you know what yeah
that sounds like something I don't even
think they have friends
and by the way it was a comedy duo so it
was him and his brother that were doing
like trying to do the key and peel type
of you know what I'm saying which is a
very hard thing to do I've only said
it's really hard
you know key and Peel's one of them and
I saw this there's this uh Duo uh comedy
in Sacramento they did it really well
but they were they were brothers and so
they kind of knew each other's like [ __ ]
very well you have to that's so hard
yeah yeah and then they were trying to
do it and I just was like oh [ __ ] dude
like if you want I'll kill you right now
to end this pain as a favor please yeah
I think it's gonna work right because
you know like some people like if they
bomb it's like it's okay right because
like I bet you this fool will be funny
something all the time I'm like you have
never been funny once in your life you
are trying so hard like that that hurts
though that hurts when you uh when when
somebody tries really hard to do a thing
and they're not
um the best at it but they try really
hard yeah
um and they just don't have the like
earlier you were saying that they don't
have the self-awareness this yeah that
that's watching that is hard but at the
same time it hurts too because they
really want to do it so sometimes you're
like kind of feel for them right you
feel for me you're like maybe
but a for effort though yeah but we're
putting yourself out there but putting
yourself out there but that's like when
I watch our buddy ant when he does uh
comedy videos on his Instagram that [ __ ]
makes me want to die so you make comedy
videos yeah all I see is you making fun
of his suits bro no no I love his suits
dude they're great
no don't don't you ever talk about my
friend that way all right you always
back on his suits bro okay I don't back
on his suits his suits are backing
did you do the makeover with them yet no
not yet because I gotta figure out where
I could donate 80 pounds of fabric but
we [ __ ] do that
I've never seen this guy dresses like
he's in like in the 2000 NBA draft like
it's it's pretty just really baggy suits
yeah I love it that's a really stupid
yeah
yeah like have you ever seen those dudes
that went to prison and they just they
left they would have been here for 20
years
yeah it's a club that they went to 20
years ago this is how this guy dresses
but he's very successful as he never
went to prison yeah
he's a great family guy I [ __ ] love
this guy he's great dude this is [ __ ]
fantastic
I love a square box
that's great
it always works bro dude that's my go-to
line that always is I always want to go
the Square Mall
no this is so funny so like we were like
dming each other and then this fool was
just like he wrote this whole thing on
um Tim's podcast right me and Tim's
podcast where n is literally the
funniest person on Earth to me because
anytime somebody asks him if he's done
something or seen a movie he goes you
know man once you have a kid like his
whole answer everything is like dude
these kids are just taking out my life
you'll ask him a simple question like
hey you want a glass of water lucky man
you know
I haven't drank you know in [ __ ] four
years you know David once you're a
father drinking water is really hard man
he's like blaming his kids why he can't
do something but I know he needs goodbye
but he always makes me laugh he's
inadvertently one of the funniest people
I've ever met in my life because I was
like making fun of him about the suits
and then on the uh on on the post on the
comment he goes like David you know when
you have kids like you give all your
life and your all your effort into your
children so things like you know
tailoring your suit or finding the right
suit doesn't really matter anymore when
you care about your family and then I
just posted it back I was like you lying
son of a [ __ ] I was like you've been
wearing those [ __ ] baggy pants since
the day I [ __ ] met you dude and so
that's why I started posting all these
pictures of him before he had his kids
yeah because that's how he's been
dressing and so I was like don't try to
lie all right David got receipts boy I
was like I got so much fun I think I did
see this thing yeah all those photos
were okay before he had the kids so it's
like you try to get the crowd against me
with the whole thing about you being an
amazing father what does the amazing
father have to do with you dressing up
as a cloud every day like I don't
understand
the guy looks like a beanbag like I
don't understand all right bro enough
dude hey hey
I love him all right you guys are
leaving at that he's a business partner
but we do like the matcha stuff together
too that's really nice I [ __ ] love
the guy great family man
um if you guys need uh realtor stuff
great dude just ignore the suit
other than that fantastic even dude I've
never seen somebody sag his shoes
[Music]
are back
this guy's gonna resist you must really
have a good relationship with you
in all seriousness
good guy
I can say anything nah bro you're right
yeah he is a good guy we literally do
business together
oh the guy can [ __ ] hoop is cute as
[ __ ] that ball is huge as his ass
my men look like Atlas like he's holding
the Earth
all right bro enough dude enough
my friends
I know all my friends leave me oh you're
all your friends
but you wrote somebody for 15 minutes
ago oh why don't they like me
Madison Square
Jason show me your penis because of
Madison Square Garden yeah
but this is what happens dude like we
but I grew up like being made fun of so
much like you just this is like if you
think I'm bad my friends are 10 times
worse than me back at home is love
though yeah if there's love you could
say that [ __ ] though but I stopped doing
it so much because I heard down the pot
like he like some I think like he's not
used to that [ __ ] so a lot of people
aren't yeah I didn't know that because
all my friends make fun like if you guys
have ever been to a [ __ ] black barber
shop get [ __ ] ready especially when
you're the only Asian guy wearing a
do-rag
that'll do it bro
there was this baby blue and white
leather [ __ ] fitted hat I used to
wear a white Scully under that [ __ ]
and none of my friends told me I was an
idiot but that was it I was popping back
that was popping if you if whenever you
would walk into the barbecue it was
Asian jokes non-stop yeah and I just had
to learn how to just cope and like fire
back at people yeah because if not
you're just the butt of the joke or you
look like you don't know how to play
yeah right and you don't want to be that
guy you want to be one of the boys yeah
right and I think too like sometimes
people think it's like traumatizing but
the other times too like on my side like
we develop like lifelong bonds yeah
because now like we do have serious
conversations but when we joke around
with each other we [ __ ] with each other
a lot but that's what I'm saying when I
[ __ ] lost all those friends on
Instagram it's because I still
it's hard over social media because like
you could take anything personally after
a while you know what I mean the uh the
intonation you can't hear it you can't
hear it yeah some of my fans though I
see a lot of my fans are so [ __ ] good
at it because like they'll say something
super dumb and I'll clap back at them
and then we'll laugh together oh that's
so [ __ ] good one person got hella mad
at me because I forgot what I said they
made this joke and then all I simply
wrote back very simple simple joke I was
like you look like you sit down when you
pee and you dab your dick after that's
it that's all I said and this person got
hella mad at me that's funny though that
was a simple [ __ ] joke they're like
oh look at this now you're making
[ __ ] like weird jokes about men's
sexual I'm like oh you know boring dude
snooze I'm getting tired of this right
now where it's like the hottest thing
like Twitter has become like the [ __ ]
stage where everything's it's like a
feelings party it's either about [ __ ]
politics somebody's calling somebody
racist or a misogynist like it's so easy
to be racist now yeah like you could do
whatever you could say whatever and
they're like look at this guy racist you
said black look at that dude you are
racist I like I'll put a post I'll be
like dude I have some Chinese food oh
really you know what they call food in
China just food oh dude I'll kill myself
yeah come on yeah they literally do like
Twitter has become this weird space now
like everybody cares ever since Elon
bought it now they're trying to make
things like they're trying to like tip
the balance over because they think he's
so right-wing they want to go super left
wing I don't know really yeah I don't
know anything about politics I just
missed the days where I would just watch
fight videos all day on Twitter where
people where there's this guy he just
talked [ __ ] to a guy he goes what's up
you want to fight and he gets clocked in
the face and he wakes up tomorrow so you
think so you so as you want as you're
going on Twitter you think it's changed
a lot since Elon bought it I there's a
few things I've been seeing a lot a lot
of complaining a lot of like is that
what Twitter is though it's even worse
now so a lot of complaining and a lot of
like uh what do you call that [ __ ] where
you kind of like think you're morally
above somebody uh where your virtue
signal virtual signaling yeah yes
and then also too a lot of porn I like
porn Okay that's always that's always
the game though the porn on Twitter is
crazy I've never seen because they're
promoting their [ __ ] I've never seen so
much titties like really on Twitter I
didn't know dude there's Twitter porn
what did you know there's Reddit porn
Dad I know okay you're but I feel like I
feel like everything like you know how
people promote their businesses on
Instagram LinkedIn Facebook Twitter
[ __ ] Tick Tock I think porn girls do
the same [ __ ] because they're all trying
to get eyes back to the only fans
because now they have a reason to
[ __ ] girls tweets are so funny and
you can't even knock these girls for
tweeting like this because there'd
always be some [ __ ] like this dude's
just [ __ ] beating off it'll be like
this it's like over this crazy fake over
hyper sexualization right it'll be like
or talk like that like
God I just really wish I had a dick in
my mouth right now
you know what the best feeling is is
when a guy comes in my ass crack and
then 30 000 likes yeah yeah but then the
guy that's buying her only fans is like
wishing he's like how come your
girlfriend doesn't talk like that dude
yeah that's not a real woman bro that's
what I'm saying can I knock the girl for
that or should I knock the [ __ ] 30
000 losers that's like oh my god dude
that's how a woman should be yeah yeah
you know and then you're like you're a
[ __ ] anyway it's like you can't win bro
you can't win bro I found out how like
just calculating like only fan stuff so
there was a girl who put out her amount
of subscribers that she has it was like
like 500 000 and it's like five thoughts
it's like five dollars a pound what what
500 000 subscribers at five dollars a
pop
[ __ ] Ballin Out of her goddamn vagina
dude what is she gonna do with all that
money I don't know she could literally
buy a new [ __ ] if she wanted to that
[ __ ] is taxes must be crazy for her okay
let's just say 50 that's still like 1
million one something million write-offs
what are you gonna write off I mean they
don't have to buy homes they're gonna
have to shoot only fans everywhere they
don't have to buy a house
they have to pay a million a text I wish
I was them so bad man you think those
only fans girls they get they get
tripped up of the [ __ ] that we get
tripped up over
I'm not an artist
they were like oh I wish someone like me
more dude I haven't posted on Instagram
in weeks because my peers think about
mine no give off yo shout out to cat
that [ __ ] selling [ __ ] assets she's
Ballin bro you know what someone asked
if she needs a personal assistant for
her it's so funny because like you know
because I follow her because I met her
on JK news she's so cool too and then
randomly I'll just see a half naked girl
oh my God yeah
yeah oh my gosh it's wild too because
it's like like I feel like you know her
and then you see her like [ __ ] in
lingerie it's like well let's and you're
like yo Bros dude I can't look at this
and my feet is not my feet is not like
that are you [ __ ] insane cover up
dude yeah what the [ __ ]
with your eyes dude Ken has a [ __ ]
fat ass how many friends of her friends
do you think like jerked off to her and
then oh a lie all of them bro
I found out like people like only fans I
think only fans like for me I will never
pay for porn ever never there's too much
free [ __ ] that you can never see all of
it yeah why why would I do this but it's
the idea of like knowing this person and
having access to them that way in which
like you would have never had before
that's true and that's the thing that
they get enticed about yes so they'll
they'll do this stuff well they'll be
like
you know
um 20 bucks and I'll talk to you for 10
minutes yeah and I'll talk dirty to you
for 10 minutes for like it'll be like a
hundred dollars and they go okay if you
I'll do 100 bucks I'll give you 500 more
if you tell me my dick is big
well but but I don't want you to tell me
the tickets I want you to lie to me okay
yeah don't lie to me oh then be honest
with it tell me tell me my dick is weird
and it curves to the left
how about yours
it's only my dick is shining on itself
tell me my dick is koi
it just does this
but they'll pay for that type of stuff
man it's [ __ ] insane and they're
actually having companies now where the
agencies right agencies where they'll
sign these only fan girls right and
they'll message for them yeah so they'll
take like a 20 cut and they don't have
to do anything all they have to do is
show [ __ ] so is Bob on the computer
oh yeah and Bob is just in the back
going like yeah you I'll show you my
[ __ ] he just say it's copy V app will
be send Applebee's how you doing Daddy
yeah bro isn't that [ __ ] insane and
they're making millions and they don't
have to do [ __ ] nothing
do you think like after because I'm just
afraid if you have a kid and then the
kid goes oh I seen your dad Jason what
are you gonna do though you know that
thing where we talked about where your
peers are judging you yeah yeah yeah
he's like [ __ ] do it already yeah
once you do that already you're gonna
listen to a podcast of me just Clowning
you for 15 minutes straight oh my only
pants like I did
at the public defender like like
right back that loses all of his cases
yeah with a briefcase with a lot of
papers
laughs
[Laughter]
he dresses like a dad that doesn't care
hey but he does care he's like the best
father ever
I love it
oh my God I think he's gonna delete my
number hey you're about to get blocked
next bro no I [ __ ] love I love these
cute ass [ __ ] kids that guy really
does work hard though like when I see
him he's a hustler bro he works too hard
that's his problem like he legit feels
like some something is going to be taken
away from him at any given time all the
time that's why he hustles so much he
does barbell stuff he does like the the
real estate stuff he does a Family
Channel he edits everything himself the
guy's [ __ ] nuts yeah
yeah part no uh Anthony Oh I thought
because you said barbell so I thought
well he works with barbell oh God I got
it yeah the guy's a [ __ ] Hustler dude
the guy works non-stop see so what are
you doing I'm a matcha King I'm not
doing that he's a matcha guy that's why
I feel bad all the time that's why I
want to do my best and
um you feel like do you really feel like
you don't do anything
I do that's why a lot of the times I
check in with my sister or my wife and I
go am I doing enough and I'm kissing
your sister bro
do you have a really close relationship
with your sister oh is my is actually my
wife's sister so I just call her sister
you know how Asian culture is just like
oh so do you have a but I do have an
actual assistant I love her too no I
love her but you don't call her though
sometimes no you know yeah I do like
once every
two months okay see this is what this is
what I'm talking about yeah you don't
like her dude I love her no not but when
it's your own sister say do you like her
though I I love her
this guy don't have his own Sisters yet
ask me again ask me again do you like
her I love her okay
he's not too quick dude see oops because
I this is what I want to see I want to
record you talking to your sister-in-law
yeah and then you record yourself
talking to your actual yeah but it's
different you know it's like hi Jenny
listen I got this problem you know
you're so good at like walking me
through all my issues and then you talk
to your sister what do you want no I
know I don't do that what do you want
are you still alive
you haven't melted yet the [ __ ] out of
here
right because you saw this [ __ ] you're
made out of ice cubes you stupid [ __ ]
go into [ __ ] water and dissolve
uh no but I love her I love both of them
but uh but you have a closer
relationship my real sister is hanging
off a cliff and then your
sister-in-law's hanging off a cliff but
you can only save one who do you save
I'm going home yeah
you jump first you jump first and you
grab your ankles yeah let's go together
that you use them as a landing pad
yeah you're [ __ ] good man I try to do
my best
why do you guys do you do you feel that
way though but it's like such a hard
balance it's like you because you were
asking them you feel like you're not
doing enough I always feel that way but
uh do you feel that way I feel like you
feel like I feel like I feel like we all
feel that way here I just hate that
feeling though I hate waking up feeling
I could have done more and that's like
my biggest fear like my biggest fear is
dying like on my deathbed and thinking I
wish I would have done more definitely
and so when I do that type of stuff it
goes into that fear again like you could
have done more how come you can't
promote yourself like these other people
do yeah you've done the work you didn't
do your best yeah and the thing is is
like these people who haven't done the
work yeah like I'm not knocking them I
want to be them but I've done the work
and I still don't do it so what's what's
stopping me right it's not like I
haven't done the work it's not like I
haven't created a you know a formerly
successful YouTube channel yeah you know
a formerly successful podcast you know
what I mean like I've done I've done the
[ __ ] work how come I can't talk about
it yeah maybe I'm afraid because it's
gonna blow up in my face like what yeah
like what specifically is gonna blow up
in your face I don't know
wait but that's weird though what make a
list
dude
square body
yeah I don't know it's a weird space to
be in yeah but especially from a person
who is doing social media first
now first as in like not first like you
got really successful because of social
media but
that's a little bit weird that like to
me because it's like you got successful
and that's why I always forget you have
anxiety and I also I always also think
that like when you're like oh man uh
it's weird to promote myself but then
you were good really good at it and also
you know how to do it so it's
interesting to see that oh you also have
a problem promoting yourself
do you know what I mean it doesn't make
sense it's weird it's a very weird space
to be in because this whole platform has
allowed me to do all the stuff that I
wanted in this world right yeah I think
that's the only reason why I feel like
I'm ready to like even try having a kid
soon because like I feel like I've done
everything that I'll do now feels good
but it'll never feel new you know what I
mean because I've been on this path for
such a long time so like you're not
pushing yourself hard enough what what
are you my father bro okay bro hey bro
I already got it Dad all right I already
got it Dad
just let it be a dude bring the walls
down brother no I already got it Jenna
you left me because he didn't love me
you know why nothing feels new because
we're in your second house next to your
first house
[Applause]
on a [ __ ] compound dude yeah no no no
no no okay
but um I've never been so poor in my
life because of this [ __ ] doobie
store
people are so funny they're like dude
you know this matcha brand must be nice
balling out like that have you seen my
[ __ ] bank account bro it costs money
to open a store
wants to own a business a business is a
is just a money pit dude that makes
money dude I'm back to looking at menus
like can I afford this
that must be nice dude that when we go
out to eat people like hey where do you
want to go we don't say I got selections
now I got places I want to go I'm like
okay we got McDonald's
we have the discount sushi spot and then
I was like oh you want to eat shaboo at
the all-you-can-eat spot next to the
Chinese place next to the garbage can
I got very special before when money's
good you're just like yeah I'll eat
anything I'll pay for you and we're all
friends Life's good not when people you
want to go out to eat I'm like [ __ ] man
I gotta go oh man I'm gonna cook
actually
I'm fasting for the rest of the week
dude I'm not ready
religious last thing dude yeah I'm a
Ramadan right now yeah okay I'm sorry
I'm in Ramadan
[Applause]
this is what I do brother this is this
is like the state that I mean people
don't know about business owners like
when we first opened up a store we're
[ __ ] poor I'm not [ __ ] Logan Paul
dude where I just have the prime drink
and it just smashes yeah I don't have
that I have to we have to run the store
look at Joe look at what Joe looks like
right now you think Joe has a lot of
money he's been pretty open with his
crypto failures the guy lost a gajillion
dollars twice like a gajillion yeah and
now he looks like a Japanese strawberry
farmer all right like where life is hard
right now I think if Joe was bawling
though he still looked like a Japanese
yeah strawberry very far I've never seen
a man so happy in my life like that guy
when I tell you this guy loves our
matcha store he [ __ ] loves it he
loves being there he loves the reaction
that people have that's the thing that I
get satisfaction to when somebody grabs
that drink and they go wow this is
really good it makes me want to cry
it's so good it feels even better than
stand up
why you gotta do this
better than selling people words all
right I sell people on actual product or
you say it like that it's in that way it
hurts
you should have Evergreen dude um feels
amazing
yeah do do you guys feel like you're not
spending a lot of like I'm curious of
what the what is the thing that you guys
like to do besides work and like how bad
do you feel that you're not spending
enough time with the people that you
want to spend or do the things that you
actually want to do because you're
working because you know is that I don't
know how often you guys talk about this
but yeah it's just that works I got my
mind more I
I never like spending time with people
like okay that came out really bad whoa
okay yeah turn it off shut it down get
the [ __ ] out of here guys it's not that
it's okay I'm actually a a Solo solo guy
so like I'll walk by myself you know I
mean like I like being around people
okay
dude just the other day are you a single
child no I have an older brother oh
that's right that's right yeah but then
I like being in my own thoughts I like
doing things by myself it's a little
weird so when I was in Sacramento I was
just there for Thanksgiving I went to a
coffee shop by myself and I was like I
look like I'm here to look at children
yeah so that's when I was like I like
that too sometimes sometimes like why
don't you have friends David how come
you couldn't have called a friend to
have coffee with them sometimes I just
like being by myself yeah so like even
if I did have more time it wouldn't be
with more people it would just be more
time to kind of stew in my own thoughts
and then you know read a book you know
you don't read books hey [ __ ]
what do you call it hey [ __ ]
what do you call these things oh you're
reading butcher plus Beast s what's that
what's that about the decoration what
kind of book is that is it a Photography
book it's a cookbook
it is this it's Angie Kmart it's just
fancy people oh it's a recipe book yes
it's a cookbook it's a lot of pictures
though a lot of more pictures and words
I think dude hey Angie K Marr she had
one one of my best dining experiences
I've ever had in my [ __ ] life I love
this song French dude she inspires the
[ __ ] out of me too this woman is so
unapologetically like carnivorous it's
unreal carnivorous what is that she
likes me like [ __ ] [ __ ] this whole
vegetarian seasonal Vegeta she does what
she does and she does it
unapologetically and I draw inspiration
everything is foie gras here dog food is
decadent the meal that I have with her
will stick with me for the rest of my
life I like that huh why I'm curious are
you calling me fat bro no yeah yeah I
heard it dude whoa that's fine are you
saying I breathe heavy when I sleep I'm
on a PAP machine at night are you are
you I used to be
why'd you bring it up congratulations it
was kind of hard yeah just here when I
was in college one of my friends
recorded me sleeping they're like hey
why'd you stop breathing suddenly you're
like and he showed me a recording on his
iPhone yeah yeah it was dangerous yeah
yeah that was scary yeah it was a rude
awakening yeah I did a little overnight
study yeah yeah my doctor said hey
you're gonna die soon yeah yeah what
else
why was it so good I was just curious
about that
oh it was delicious
she had this duck dish that she lit on
fire that's tight the best duck I've
ever had in my life so [ __ ] amazing
she had like this she dry ages her own
[ __ ] beef [ __ ] amazing I love but
see this is what I'm talking about I
gained inspiration from just about it it
doesn't have to be Comics yeah I gained
inspiration from people who truly love
what they do and they [ __ ] tackle it
and I want to be like that I want to be
just like them I want to have that
unwavering faith in me yeah I feel like
they still care a little bit just we
care more of course they care everybody
cares I feel like it's just that they're
so focused and so strong in their thing
even though sometimes people say stuff
or whatever like Giro Dreams of Sushi I
don't want to be like that intense but
you know the guy's like 400 years old
and he's like I still have to get better
yeah and I'm like Doc but you think for
those guys they just have unwavering you
said unwavering at confidence right you
think it's just because in their craft
they just know that like yo what I'm
providing to the world like what my my
Avenue is just so good they just know it
right like the Avenue yeah like they
spent so much time in it they have so
much confidence in their craft that they
know that like [ __ ] I need to do one
thing and just [ __ ] do it that's a
big thing too yeah some people just like
different some people like to open a
Walmart and some people like to uh make
a tire rim the whole life yeah and
that's probably [ __ ] Walmart dude
yeah is that that's a good that's good
that's big business what's the biggest
business what are you talking about have
you seen people of walmart.com that's
different yeah that's different that's
the people that shop
Target I forgot about Target I just said
because they're so big it's a great
business too everybody knows Walmart not
a okay people know Target too
[Applause]
Taiwan or Korea not everybody knows
Target but if you go to Taiwan people
you go to Walmart and he's like yeah I
know Walmart yeah do I mean that's what
I'm saying people like to say so people
in Taiwan know Walmart yeah people in
Korea know Walmart too for sure
if you no you don't think so I think so
okay maybe not
yeah I never saw Walmart in Taiwan no
not uh not Walmart but I think they know
about it then it changed to I think they
know yeah aren't you Taiwanese too
dude I'm I don't think I'm really Asian
if anything I think you're Mexican every
time I see him he's like hanging out
with my friends it's like him in like a
sea of Mexican people or salvadorians
yeah I got a lot of brown most of my
friends are brown you know it's so
fascinating like if you have mostly
brown and black folks but you look like
that though I'm a little I think I'm his
first Asian friend dude honestly you
were one of my first Asian friends like
I'll be real like when I started doing
when I started hanging around with David
I would like asking questions like hey
do your parents do this and he's like
yeah yeah or he'll like talk about his
family and on my head I'm like oh that's
some Asian [ __ ] though oh or like when
we did JK and like everyone would talk
about like their family upbringing and
like how their parents were just like
way meaner to them than everyone else's
family is like parents like did your
parents say I Love You by ignoring you
and then they'd be like oh yeah me too
and I'd be like oh [ __ ] like that's some
Asian [ __ ] like like it took me a while
to kind of articulate or just figure out
that like
what I was going through was a cultural
thing and not just like something that
was only specific to me you know but
yeah most of the friends I had were all
like brown that's really cool though
because now you have like different um
cultural background and friends and
stuff like that he knows more Spanish
words than he does know I don't know
like Mandarin I barely know any Mandarin
bro but like when I go when I hear
people speak Spanish I can understand
like a good chunk of it I will say this
when I was in Taiwan I liked Taiwanese
Mandarin a lot it was very uh pretty it
sounded more like Japanese like when you
hear like Mainland Mandarin it's like
worse like it don't have any of that
[ __ ] a lot harder so I could hear
separate words I was like oh this is
very pleasant I enjoy not that Mainland
Mandarin is not that Pleasant I'm not
hitting on you know worse
like you know I get it I get it yeah you
know a little sounds like you got a
little you know dick in your throat I
get it
I like it I like hey that's what I do
that's what yeah it is what you like but
when I was in Taiwan I was like oh this
is different it's the Japanese influence
is very very heavy in Taiwan that's true
right because when I went there I was
like I really like Taipei it's cool I
mean for some reason it's just stupid
hot all the [ __ ] time yeah and I was
there during their cold season and it
was like a thousand degrees and people
were in puff jackets yeah what the [ __ ]
is that about yeah well people just uh
are more accepting of hot weather a
little bit no nobody's really accepting
however but we could just tolerate it
more but the but the language thing
um I feel like the reason why we're more
like soft is because maybe we lost the
Civil War
and then we went to the island and we're
just accepting of other things like
there's no choice
[Laughter]
so so we have a lot of Japanese
influence we accept it because
can we take it
Hello Kitty
at the same time
we take the good and the best
this is my country like you guys like
okay
you open a 7-Eleven right here and you
only serve a really delicious food in a
7-Eleven okay there's a lot of services
that's why they just left they're like
they said too easy no fun you fight back
like accordion people you know
she fight back
that's why they just left they're like
no fun
no fun at the time
I just heard that so many times every
time
this [ __ ] saying excuse me everywhere
yeah very polite that's why earlier you
were saying about the bantering thing
they were talking about the bantering
thing I think because Taiwanese culture
is so polite that is that's something
that I have to learn and still learning
is the bantering thing is that sometimes
it's hard to do because you're not
supposed to you're always supposed to be
polite first yeah and I grew up in that
and but some people are good at
bantering Taiwan but the majority in the
general uh thing is that I see I'm
learning more of that now because I was
so so like too straightforward I'm
learning to like reel backwards a little
bit but the thing is oh you're real back
now but this is real bad bro yeah I did
but the thing is intention
he's seen me like how straightforward I
could be with like straight up
and also like I've I've met David what
probably like four or five years now for
five years and like already I think he
was already kind of tame and [ __ ] or
like by the time I got to hang out with
them more but like we we're hanging out
in a big group and then there's just
somebody that he doesn't like that he
doesn't really Vibe with and then
they'll be like David won't even
acknowledge their existence like there
might as well be an empty chair in front
of them like there's nobody [ __ ]
there though
what hello I said Siri what the [ __ ] oh
that was a the iMac that scared the [ __ ]
don't be a [ __ ] dude it's just cereal
well that's scary but also like when
David is he doesn't [ __ ] with you yeah
he's just like
he's so cold well here's the thing I've
learned if you don't don't say anything
if something nice is not coming out your
mouth that's the phrase go when you say
when you when you don't like something
it's better to say something nothing but
then he just doesn't acknowledge you're
[ __ ] up my English and I'm talking
like you something
I was like what when you don't have
anything nice to say You Say Nothing at
All
that's true that's what I was saying so
I've learned that it was not original
it's just like I know who you're talking
about too it's uncomfortable dude I'm
just like oh but this guy will literally
talk to me and I'm just like
and his face dude like he has he kind of
has a good like resting [ __ ] face
sometimes like it's scary so I'm not
gonna be talking to him and I know David
like he likes me to a certain degree
right yeah not that much but as soon as
I'll be talking to him and he'll be
looking at me and I'll think like am I
[ __ ] [ __ ] or something
am I saying something like it did I say
something racist because I'm listening
dude I'm listening so much
he just falls asleep I've gotten a lot
better dude I've gotten so much better
but sometimes it's really really really
bad it might be a defense better for how
I grew up you know just like learning to
just separate things very well but
that's why I've kept friends for a very
long time but that's good too but the
one thing about David though that I
really appreciate is that he honest like
I know he gonna tell me he gonna call me
on my [ __ ] he's gonna tell me what
I'm gonna [ __ ] not always though I
feel like Dave is nice sometimes too to
the people that he likes yeah that's
true yeah
this I'm here and here like if I dislike
you yeah oh I [ __ ] dislike you a lot
yeah that's why I just tend not to just
think about them at all I just ignore
them because I think that's healthy it's
better I kind of like it though I kind
of like it because if not I'll do
everything to make their life [ __ ]
miserable because you don't want to give
energy to that yeah so I put all that
energy into like supporting my friends
and stuff right so I'll just do that
instead because before I did things on
Avengers just like I'm like it's a great
way to live by the way I was like oh
this person's a piece of [ __ ] nobody
knows I'll make sure everybody [ __ ]
knows how trash this person is and I
will [ __ ] do it until every person in
our group understands how terrible of a
[ __ ] human being this is oh my God
yeah and I would do it and it would work
yeah scary in it it would [ __ ] work
because I also felt too at the time and
this is not healthy I'm not saying you
guys should do this and like the
specific person who I did this to they
were just so good at [ __ ] lying to
everybody he would [ __ ] everybody over
and then everybody would just be
blindsided by it but nobody would talk
about in the group so I would just like
we were at this uh bar let's say a bar
I'm trying to change up certain aspects
of the story so change a lot more we
were at a bar
and literally we're talking and I'm just
like so you owe this person money you
[ __ ] didn't pay that tap and you were
talking [ __ ] about this person why what
happened like everybody's like quite I
was like don't and I looked at everybody
pissed off I was like I'm tired of
[ __ ] hanging out with everybody all
you guys [ __ ] hate this guy and you
[ __ ] invite them so pay this person
[ __ ] back venmo this [ __ ] right now
and why the [ __ ] have you been talking
so much [ __ ] but uh everyone every
friend who needs a game though yeah
because it cuts the [ __ ] you know
because they got so awkward where
everybody and I hated this [ __ ] about
like the people at the time and I don't
even hang out with any of these
[ __ ] anymore it's because they
would talk so much [ __ ] about him but
they would invite him out to events and
they would treat him like a friend
that's like weird things with their
friends though exactly I was like you
guys might be worse than he is right
because don't invite this [ __ ]
yeah if it's not supposed to be like you
actively hate this guy because you could
have nip this in the bud yes right and
now I have to play Daddy you got to get
your venmo back you got to get this [ __ ]
back and this guy's like oh I didn't say
any of this stuff and then I'm like if
you guys don't speak up it's about to
get awkward and then people start
talking yeah and they go okay and then
he finally apologizes and he [ __ ]
cleans up his act a little bit that's
great and I take him aside and then we
just share drinks I'm like what the [ __ ]
is your problem that's a positive thing
that's a really good thing a lot of
people won't do that though they'll just
[ __ ] stew in this little
uncomfortable things dude that's why I
don't have friends
I don't want to Stew I don't want to
Stew I just rather not stew and not did
you have any like groups of friends that
like you would have issues like that
with no I never liked doing that like I
never liked to do that and that's why
I'm like okay then I'll just be with the
people that I like and there's so little
of the people because I accept their
flaws and I love them even though with
their flaws and they're good you know
people but uh but whenever I don't want
to be fake because it's so tiring it's
exhausting because with work already you
have to be you know coaches a little bit
yeah she moves a little bit already I
used to get [ __ ] up in JK news so much
because you know Sacramento is such a
small town right and like I've I used to
get my dad used to beat the living [ __ ]
out of me for any type of Life white lie
whatever right yeah but when you're on
something like JK news and you're
telling these life stories you you're
from a small town you have to change
details yeah and I was so bad at lying
I'm like fumbling over my words as I'm
telling you these stories sometimes and
I remember I would go home like [ __ ] you
know what I mean I hate it it felt like
it literally felt like people were
ripping pieces of my soul out because I
had to keep doing I've gotten better at
it now we're now like a white lie I
could change like details of stories a
lot better yeah and a lot of times I
still [ __ ] up so I could delete it out
of the podcast or I could bleep out
names but like in the beginning of JK
news it was really hard for me because I
had to because it came back with like I
wish you didn't tell that story I'm like
[ __ ] Sacramento Small Town yeah so I
I chose to like learn how to white lie a
bit better than Mariel told me I have to
learn how to white lie it's like when I
when I say like hey how does my hair
look even if you hate it say something
nice first and then change it after
because before I'd be like who the [ __ ]
did that to your head yeah like why
would they do that to you but you know
what but the intention matters like you
were [ __ ] on Anne Aunt yeah ant yeah
you know I have 75 minutes but you love
him but the thing is like I feel like
intention to me is everything like it
doesn't matter if you're showing
something before but I understand that
some people can't see that like some
people's like oh you can't you don't
want to say like the friend that blocked
you twice that she didn't see the
intention yeah I deserved that one yeah
I knew the first time when she blocked
me I didn't have to read what was the
post that you made that comment on like
what did she post uh she posted a
picture of her nose job
okay
but here's the thing I thought it was
appropriate because no jobs were good
she looked good oh yeah yeah then you're
punching up yeah yeah because the nose
job looked good if it was a bad nose job
you wouldn't have said yeah I wouldn't
have said [ __ ] yeah like literally like
she had such a small nose before it was
like tiny as [ __ ] like she looked like a
cadaver and so like before she got now
she you know she got a bigger nose and I
was like oh it looks good oh [ __ ] yeah
that makes sense you could do that yeah
that's okay whenever if you have a nice
thing it's okay to [ __ ] on it like yeah
that's what I was thinking yeah you know
what I mean but then I think it was the
jokes that came after that it's just
funny we were like yes I came after not
not the [ __ ] that you said yeah it
wasn't my phone
David said it's okay
it was his soldiers it was it was the
[ __ ] soldiers how was your mind bro
this guy that's a good point I just made
a very very passionate speech
what they do after is completely up to
them
you're a piece of [ __ ] dude
by the way I [ __ ] hate Hitler and I
do not condone Kanye West I just want to
say that his shoes
oh yes we're very brave of you hey guys
David [ __ ] hates Hitler okay what is
your problem
hey yo dude I don't even know what this
means what is this Kyle brother is that
what their thing is I don't know I know
nothing about the Holocaust I don't hear
that I just don't okay I like Jojo
rabbit you ever see JoJo very good very
very it makes it funny yeah you see JoJo
rabbit you should watch it it's [ __ ]
very very it's very good really really
good comedy movie about something that
shouldn't be funny yeah yeah whoa dude
that was a sign hello that was it that
was that was
oh yeah nobody answered yeah hey [ __ ]
Hitler right guys yeah yeah hey we're in
agreeance yeah no more hits out to the
people that's somebody no that's
different that's why power no oh is this
white power no that's not white power oh
okay I think of the Olympics I think
Olympics Olympics yeah okay good all
right dude
yeah that's my blood yeah
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast I uh you guys
can catch Jason Cheney uh performing you
know if you have any type of shows
coming out when we post this I'll let
you know when it posts I'll put it in
the screen that's really nice thank you
for doing doing that yeah so you gotta
catch this [ __ ] every person
that like saw you on the play because I
saw you that saw you like live they
[ __ ] loved it you're a hit dude
you're really nice you're a [ __ ] hit
I want to be like man we just we just
we're hanging out with you because we
know you're gonna be a big deal you're
really nice we're writing coattails yeah
we're getting and yeah this is like it's
like Bitcoin when it was like three
thousand dollars you know I want to say
this before uh the uh and David's
podcast okay yeah no
um that you guys are really nice and
thank you for believing to me that's
really nice
it's the nonchalant game
heterosexual dude yeah dude what do you
want to kiss us after a dream at a row
your sister-in-law dude
what's up [ __ ] sister lover yeah bro
you're [ __ ] weird we take everything
back dude
I can't wait for your special dude yeah
dude you're [ __ ] awesome I cannot
[ __ ] wait for it it's gonna [ __ ]
blow the [ __ ] up and then you're gonna
have these people come after you uh not
in a good way for like hey we want to
put you on Netflix well I'll do all this
other stuff and when it happens just
know
that we were here for you
you guys are really nice man I really do
appreciate it and and oh the thing is
that uh you guys always uh the support
that you guys give each other and that
everybody that you guys uh support
including me is that um it's like it
feels genuine and it feels nice and um
it's not like you know so I really
appreciate that because that's really
rare to have somebody that don't know
you and just like what you do and maybe
like you as a maybe like you as a person
that's really nice listen if you sucked
at what you did oh God you would never
be on here oh yeah
I would be throwing light jazz at you
all day on this podcast yeah just kind
of ripping you but because I enjoy your
content you made me giggle first and
this is why I appreciate it I lost
respect for you at first when you lost
that boxing match and I decided to watch
your stand up and I was like this is why
he lost he's a funny guy
he's not meant to be a fighter yeah he's
a lover you're a lovable you're a funny
dude you're not meant to fight nope I
try to be you do your [ __ ] rounds on
stage yeah that's what you do all right
that's where the real magic is next year
Nick you need to get a gold medal in Jiu
Jitsu I did I'll get a couple bro how
about that yeah there it is
you know what it is man you're going to
yep I'll be fine and then dude and I you
know also remember too like you gotta
pay to do these competitions 100 so
going as a white belt yeah and then
[ __ ] smash everybody do my [ __ ] up
ears and [ __ ] you know yeah what is this
all my plotto
tutorial on YouTube
oh God She Knows by your ears you're a
black belt good God
you can catch Nick at Nick the ear NT
East strong get your personal training
in the man will get you fit and ready
for the new [ __ ] year and we have a
gym now in Pasadena so so come by come
train with your boys yes and if you guys
want to learn you got that Lion Heart
Lion Heart baby that's right choke
people out show them that you love them
by making sure they never wake up until
tomorrow
it's a good plug okay Lionheart Jiu
Jitsu we kill people temporarily